so we're looking at freedom mores it's a
brand new exclusive for the position
Vita it's a third-person action game
kind of in the same vein as those kind
of hunting games you've seen before kind
of like you know I want to say like
maybe master hunter or toukiden soul
sacrifice where the emphasis is on four
player combat but this game has so very
rich single-player story set in a
post-apocalyptic kind of dystopia so
think 1984 you're constantly being
watched
actually our prisoner over here our
sinner as he is called has a million
year life sentence at the beginning of
the game we can actually see his counter
on the top of his head over there he is
eight hundred and thirty seven thousand
years to go so as you're playing through
the story you're going to be whittling
down those years the idea is that you're
completing missions for this big
government this panopticon on which you
live and the better you do in these
missions the more years you'll take off
and the closer you'll get to earning
your free day
standing right here next to me is my
accessory so she's my kind of my
assistant she's an AI
she's she's a robotic but she's also my
parole officer so she's kind of in
charge of reporting me if I do anything
wrong to society as well as helping me
in battle so you know this kind of
love-hate relationship there
she plays into the story a lot too so
you'll see in some of our trailers the
center of the character is constantly
trying to help his accessory but you
know she's also there to tattle on you
too so got to make sure you don't break
the rules in this mission I'm actually
going to be going after an abductor and
rescuing a citizen that got captured I
chose some of the other characters from
the story to help me out I'm playing the
single-player right now
so unlike a lot of those previous games
where you know sometimes the grind was a
little tough if you did it by yourself
you know taking on huge monsters by
yourself can be pretty tough but in this
game everybody you encounter in the
story is going to be you know someone
that you can select a fight with you on
your team so here's just a very basic
map we've got some smaller enemies
around you can see I'm using and just
ago a machine gun right now check out
some of these smaller guys I'm going to
instruct my team over here to basically
cover me and we'll go and try and find
that there it is so that's an abductor
right there this is kind of close the
beginning you can see my other AI
friends are actually jumping on him
trying to distract him he'll come after
me so you know it's really all about
teamwork and what I'm using right now is
my foreign it's kind of like a grappling
hook to grab onto him and to drag him
down the more of us that are hooked on
than at once
the faster that he'll go and then as
soon as I can drag him down it's time to
get in and strike him so if you notice
once he stands back up you'll see in the
middle of his body there's a yellow
capsule that's actually where our
civilian is so you can see she's up
there so I'm going to go up there with
my thorn and grab
out and then me actually transporting
her back to our transport pod is going
to be when the mission actually is
computer the game is for players so four
people can play it once but every every
character every player has an accessory
so you're constantly bringing eight
characters into battle and trust me when
I say for for all the missions that
you're able to you're going to want to
bring a full team in you know we'll have
situations where you're fighting for you
know three or four huge enemies and
numerous smaller enemies at the same
time so again very simple mission we
actually killed the abductor pretty
quickly since all of my characters are
pretty little old but that's just a
basic example a very simple mission we
can always approach the window on
Liberty and customize our characters I
can always request physical remodeling
which will let me change the gender the
complete look of my character as well as
the accessory so really you can make
your guy look however you want tons of
different you know body types and let's
just get through a few of them get set
the high you could get pretty much like
customize any element of this the eyes
eyebrows you name it and then when you
get costumes you'll actually unlock
costumes for both you and your accessory
so you'll constantly be coordinated you
can give your character glasses have
phones etc you can really make them look
whatever you want it's completely up to
you everything in this game again you
start out as a sinner with a million
year sentence must be unlocked and to do
that you have to unlock these
entitlements and entitlements can be
everything from regular activities like
the right to pace around in your room to
the right to use better weapons you get
these entitlements and you're allowed to
unlock them as you go through the story
in the game but really everything that
you're able to do in the game everything
that will help you in combat is going to
be something that you
so the better you do in the actual
combat itself in the missions the more
points you will receive and the more
things you'll be able to form quickly so
it's a balancing act you want to make
sure you're you know not only looking
good and unlocking the costumes but you
want to make sure that you're actually
also unlocking better thorns and the
thorn is down grappling-hook you had as
well as gear for your other characters
as well there's lots of customization
options which point of the ounce of DLC
actually coming in the next month - a
lot of free DLC so we're going to have a
lot of different ways that you can
customize your characters and keep them
looking unique so then you go online and
you look like anybody else
this is freedom ores it is an exclusive
title for the PlayStation Vita it is out
October 28th both retail and digital for
29
could you see macaca knees